hey what's up guys mkbhd here with
google's nexus 10. it's a flagship super
high resolution android tablet of course
it's made by samsung and sold by google
and this review video i'll try to give
you a couple of things that you might
want to know about this tablet if you're
considering buying it and basically what
differentiates it from other tablets
that i've already reviewed the first
differentiation is on the outside the
design and the build and this is an
interesting combination of specs on this
tablet on the outside you have a
hardened plastic build that feels pretty
good in the hand it's pretty lightweight
about 600 grams and it feels great
especially because of the awesome tacky
material on the back it really surprised
me in the unboxing that i did and i
definitely still love it even though it
is a super fingerprint magnet i still
love it it's a super simple design
really with the pogo pins down at the
bottom the volume and power buttons up
top and the overall slightly curved
design in order to fit well in two hands
in landscape mode and it has these
awesome front-facing triple channel
speakers these are great for media
consumption which we'll get to in a
second and you can't even really cover
them all with your hands because they're
such large speakers something also
that's weird about the volume buttons is
when you go from landscape to portrait
mode the volume buttons are backwards so
the top brings volume down and the
bottom brings volume up so that's
something you'll have to get used to a
little quirky at the top of the back
here is a removable panel with magnets
underneath for a future smart cover like
accessory that hopefully google will
start selling in the play store very
soon there's also a 5 megapixel camera
and flash in the middle which actually
takes some pretty decent shots but then
again why would you take pictures with
the tablet anyway below that is a 9 000
milliamp hour battery which easily
lasted me days on end with medium use it
did take a little extra time to charge
because it's such a big battery but it
was worth it and you got about five
hours of screen on time the next thing
you should know about this tablet is the
internals this guy is rocking an exynos
5 dual core cpu with the mali t604 gpu 2
gigabytes of ram and up to 32 gigabytes
of sealed storage benchmarks indicate
that this is a mid-range device with
solid power basically but these
benchmarks don't exactly translate well
into real-life performance speaking of
performance this thing flies and that's
because of the next thing that
differentiates this tablet from others
is that it is indeed a nexus it's
running stock pure android 4.2 jelly
bean so the tablet layout for android
has changed so now you get those same
back home and multitasking software
buttons down at the bottom that you get
on phones i don't know if i like this
more or less than the older honeycomb
layout but i can see why they changed it
another change is the split pull down
trays so the one on the left is for your
regular notifications and the one on the
right is your quick settings so you get
all sorts of settings controls and this
works particularly well for me on a
tablet because i am constantly adjusting
things like screen brightness toggling
wi-fi on and off turning auto rotation
on and off and more but you can even
toggle multiple user accounts from here
so it's all just a swipe down away and
it's pretty useful to me also as usual
i'll reference you guys to my video
linked down below in the description
below the like button on this video in
which i cover everything that is new in
android 4.2 jelly bean the next unique
thing you need to know about this tablet
is easily the most important it is that
this is a
2560 by 1600 ips display
my gosh this thing handles the best
looking mobile display out there now it
takes a couple of things to make such a
display a good experience not only does
it have to be a good quality display but
you need the content to take advantage
of it you need the apps games movies
videos software fonts icons you need so
many things to be optimized for such a
high-res display
content optimization it's what we'll
call it and content optimization is
what's missing on this tablet right now
first of all there aren't a whole lot of
apps that are optimized for android
tablets to begin with so when you open
them they have the telltale signs of a
phone icon and they run the phone app in
landscape mode and on top of that there
are very few apps that are optimized to
take full advantage of this high density
300 ppi display so there will be apps
that work perfectly on this tablet
layout but you'll be able to see where
certain developers used lower resolution
icons or didn't update their graphics
fully so you'll be able to see
pixelization in some apps that being
said the apps and games that do work and
are optimized for tablets and are
optimized for this display look
phenomenal especially with text you'll
see text in something like google books
or google play magazines they are the
most
impressive parts of when you're looking
at things are optimized for this display
also high resolution images really stand
out and pop this isn't an amoled display
so the contrast ratios aren't quite as
high as some of the other tablets like
the galaxy note 10.1 but i'd honestly
rather have this ips display for
immediate consumption than any other
that exists right now android itself is
optimized google apps are optimized the
keyboard is optimized and you'll notice
that super crisp text pretty much
everywhere through android menus and
graphics all of them are high quality so
that's the first thing that's optimized
and but just you know when you're buying
a new tablet like this you're pretty
much waiting on the ecosystem to catch
up to it gaming can be a phenomenal
experience but you'll be waiting on
games to play that actually look
phenomenal because they were all built
you know originally for 1280x720
displays the games i found that are
fully optimized for the nexus 10
seriously have me holding on to this
tablet and keeping it for the future of
what this experience will be like and
google is doing their fair share and
encouraging developers and people like
that to update their apps their icons
their graphics etc to look great on a
display like this that being said right
now it's really hit or miss simply
because this display is so far ahead of
its time either way the nexus 10 is in
stock right now as soon as i'm doing
this narration right now it is in stock
in the play store so don't even waste
your time check it out the link is below
this video 4g nexus 10 might be the
dream but there is only a wi-fi only
model of this guy for now to wrap it all
up this is an excellent tablet for an
excellent price
just enough ahead of its time for it to
become its biggest weakness
for now
if you guys have any questions or
anything you want to know about this guy
feel free to leave that in the comments
section below where you can see me
answering them and if you want to see
more videos like this go ahead and
subscribe that's it that's the nexus 10
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the very next video
peace
you